Attention, très bonne nouvelle en ce début d'vidéo !
Un ballon gonflé pour la vidéo daltonisme
Est encore gonflé après plusieurs mois !
Nozman j'aimerai que t'en par.. *bruit de ballon dégonfler*
Pas d'bonne nouvelle finalement
On est là pourquoi aujourd'hui ; pour une raison très simple.
Pour la suite des photos montages
La dernière fois on avait bien ris, on s'était marrés, on avait bien rigolé
Tous ensemble. Je pense qu'un jour je vais devenir beauf sans m'en rendre compte et je serais comme ça naturellement
J'vous ai tweeté de nouvelles photos de moi sur fond vert. Le but étant bien sûr de retirer la couleur verte et de m'incruster où vous le souhaitez
pour que ça est du sens, qu'il y est des montages cools et propres ! C'est pas ce que j'ai vu là...
*musique datant des années 50*
C'EST QUOI CA ??! Si vous savez pas faire de montage photo, n'en faites pas les amis !
faut pas vouloir passer dans une vidéo à tout prix au point de proposer un truc nul !
Attention tout le monde n'a pas fait un truc nul. En fait si vous voulez y a tellement de photos montages de qualité genre level 1
Que c'est dur de trouver ceux qui sont biens mais bon
Qu'est ce que vous avez fait avec tout ça ? C'est parti !
Eh mais... Dans toutes les vidéos vous me calez avec des titans... C'est un truc de ouf !
Et dans toutes les vidéos vous avez du mal à retirer la couleur verte
''J't'avais pas vu la première fois que j'avais vu le film'' C'est pas maaal ! Y a un problème de proportion. Oh quoi que ?
Quoi que finalement peut-être que j'fais la taille de la patte de ce lion hein ! On est pas a l'abri hein (wtf x) ) OK SUIVANT!
dragon ball squeezie
Ah une petite BD j'aime bien les BD
*lis la BD* qui est là ?
*lis la BD* Squeezie je dois supprimer ce youtubeur qui perverti nos jeunes !
ok
*lis la BD* non mec stp
*lis la BD* ha l'batard !
c'est mal mais personne n’achèterais ma BD si c'est des choses comme ça qu'il y a dedans
*lis* likez le plus possible pour qu'il le voit pas : je l'ai jamais vu aussi déterminé
c'est dégueu parce que la résolution de la photo est dégueulasse
mais c'est pas mal hein
ho putain quelqu'un qui a fait un jeu
*lis* où est Squeezie ? trouver les 8 squeezie cachés !
sympatique ça, très bonne idée
une petite photo de New York Times
On en a un qui est la et qui donne un coup de poing a McDonald's
Ce vilain clown qui terrorise des enfants
On en a un qui est là ambiance posée
Un qui tombe
Un qui est assis
Déjà ceux en l'air c'est les plus simples, parce que y a personne en l'air à par moi finalement
Ok il y en a un là, putain il est bien caché l'batard
Oooh ouiii bieeen
il nous en reste 2 à trouver
Ok là il vole
Le dernier il est où ?
Oh non c'est horrible quand tu trouves pas le dernier c'est affreux c'est le pire moment
il y en a 8 ça se trouve c'est un troll il y en a 7
tu ne serait pas pervers à ce point leloulze
Huit !!!! en train de courir sur la route putain
Il était dur à voir celui là
voila Squeezie montage
hooo meeec !!!!
ça c'est bien pensé, ça ça fait plaisir
Quand je vois ça j'aime internet
C'est trop malin, j'ai lâché un gros j'aime
Trop de créativité dans cet homme. Ok une BD !
*lis* J'ai mis 2h pour faire cette BD, je compte sur vous pour qu'il puisse la voir"
Cela te rappelle quelques souvenirs non ?
*lis* "C'est à mon tour de jouer, dégage !"*ris* Ha, ha ok... Je vois déjà où tu veux en venir
C'est une vieille histoire que j'ai raconté dans une vieille vidéo
*lis* "non pas maintenant je termine ma partie Dofus" *ris après avoir vu l'image suivante*
C'est tellement ça qu'il a fait c'te batard
Il a parfaitement débranché l'ordinateur *lis* "Non tu n'avais pas le droit !!!"
*lis* "Aah !" J'ai tapé dans un cadre *ris après avoir vu l'image dans le cadre*
Il a mis un cadre de Cyprien *lis* Paff !
Et grosse ambulance !
Tu l'as si bien constitué à l'aide d'images, tu sais c'est comme les, les...
Ok c'est bon je me confesse, des fois il y a des trucs un peu nul
genre euh les inspecteurs qui raconte un truc
et pour pas que ça soit juste un mec
qui parle pendant 30 minutes devant la caméra il
reconstitue les scènes, ok ? Bref, là où je veux en venir
c'est que tu reconstitues aussi bien que les scènes bilans
et en faite... *lis* "jeu des sept différences, have fun"
Ok... Euh...
Mec c'est chaud
Euh le truc de New York
Ah non j'avais même pas vu, c'est juste que c'est pas du tout la même personne !
Excellent merci à tous au revoir salut
*regarde et écoute la musique*
*ris* Haha elle est trop bien la choré
elle avait la même pose que moi sur l'une des photos
regarde elles sont comme ça
en plus juste elle elle ouvre sa jupe donc je trouve ça plus sexy
*Squeezie danse*
Oh putain je vais faire carrière en Corée. Suivaaant !
*lis* "Je ne sais pas faire de montage mais j'ai quand même
réussi à mettre la photo dans l'autre sens" *ris*
Je suis fatigué de ces âneries, j'allais dire conneries
*lis* "Un amour qui durera éternellement"
Ooh *ris* C'est mignooon
Arrêtez vous me saoulez de mettre du Trico
J'ai envie de chialer
*lis* "Mes croquettes ou la vie"
*ris* Putain c'est tellement fait avec les moyens du bord c'est beau
La pire photo de Jumbo, la main
c'est un emoji mon pote *ris* On sent que y avait pas de compétence requise
Pour faire un montage mec ça
Mais ça c'est quand même ... ça me fait plaisir
*lis* "Squeezie montage allez j'en rajoute une après les 4 autres (tweet précédent) ! Une photo extraite du #FortBoyard de samedi avc Squeezie"
Alors, c'est pas exactement
mais c'est comme ça *montre l'extrait*
Parce que oui
j'ai fait Fort Boyard ça a été difficile, c'était samedi dernier
dire que ma grand-mère, Mauricette, elle a été très heureuse
très très heureuse et avec l'anecdote
Attention parce que c'était la vidéo anecdote, c'est fou
Avant l'émission j'étais avec Tex
Le présentateur des Z'amours et je me suis dis, les Z'amours ceux qui regarde ça
C'est les gens d'un certain âge. Donc j'envoie une photo de moi avec Tex
et je l'envoie à ma grand-mère je savais pas si elle le connaissait
alors elle me répond
c'est génial, j'ai encore le screen ! Regardez ! J'ai encore le screen !
C'est génial ! *lis* Regarde avec qui je suis !
On est à l'hôtel à côté du fort"
Ma grand-mère a répondu : Quelle surprise !
Il va pouvoir te soutenir moralement, j'ai hâte de voir comment ça va se passer, bisous à vous deux !"
J'ai appris plus tard, que ma grand-mère a cru
que sur la photo, Tex était en faite,
mon frère. *se retient de rire*
J'ai beaucoup ris, j'étais aussi très triste
En me disant "Non mais mamie ! T'es yeux vont bien ?!"
*lis* "Quand Squeezie surprend sa figurine
en train de faire des avances à Max" Quelle horreur ! Oh !
Vilain ! Tu es vilain ! *frappe Jackie-chan*
Des fois il
a besoin d'une petite correction ce batard
*lis* "La dernière fois que j'ai pris l'avion, j'ai regardé par le hublot et j'ai vu ça."
On en est là... ça je saurais pas le faire par exemple
Il y a quand même de... un bel effort mais c'est quand même pas drôle c'est triste
*ris* J'adore vanner *lis* Fais en ce que tu veux...
Send nudes, fait de moi-même. Mais mec
Si j'envoie à une fille elle est obligée de m'envoyer un nude
Grâce à toi c'est fou. C'est nuuul
y a même pas de blague !